اوكرانيا وروسيا تتبادلان الاتهامات بشان
السد امام مجلس الامن واشنطن تقول انها
ليست متاكده
ولي العهد السعوديه استعرضوا مع وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه العلاقات الثنائيه
والقضايا الاقليميه والدوليه
الاطراف الليبيه تفشل في التوقيع على
اعلانه بوزنيقه رغم حديثا عن توافقات
الليبيه الليبيه المهمه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر عقد
مجلس الامن الدولي جلسه بطلب الروسيا
الاوكراني لمناقشه ازمه تفجير سد كخوفكا
في خرسون جنوبي اوكرانيا وكيلو الامين
العام للامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه قال
ان 40 بلده غمرتها المياه في خرسون جراء
تفجير السد
واضافت في كلمته ان الوضع الانساني في
اوكرانيا يتدهور بسبب تفجيره سد كفوفكا
محذرا من انخفاض منسوب المياه في السد
سيؤثر على محطه زبالوجيا النوويه
من الواضح ان التبعاتي ستكون مدمره على
الاف الاشخاص في جنوب اوكرانيا وعلى جانبي
خط المواجهه فهم محرومون من السكن
والغذائي والاهياه الصالحه للشرب واخرون
خسروا حياتهم المياه التي كانت وراء السد
كانت مصدر حياه للمنطقه ليس فقط في خرسون
ولكن ايضا في زابوريجيا وديني برو وسلطات
الاوكرانيه اعلنت ان اربعين بلده غمرت
بالمياه بشكل كامل او جزئي ومن المتوقع ان
يرتفع هذا الرقم
من جهته اتهم المندوب الروسي لدى مجلس
الامن الجيش الاوكراني بتدمير من اجل
الحصول على مكاسب عسكريه مؤكدا وجود
العديد من المواطنين الذين لابد من
اجلائهم فورا من المناطق المحيطه
بالسدره
في اليوم الماضي قامت حكومه كييف بارتكاب
جريمه وهي تدمير المحطه الكهرومائيه والسد
على نهر دنيبرو هناك ملايين الناس الذين
سيتضررون ولابد من اجلائهم فورا بسبب
الفيضانات هناك اضرار هائله خاصه ما يتعلق
بالقطاع الزراعي الجيش الاوكراني يسعى منذ
مده لتدمير هذا السد للحصول على منافع
عسكريه وهذا ما كانت قد اشارت اليه واشنطن
بوست العام الماضي
في المقابل اتهم مندوب واوكرانيا دائم لدى
الامم المتحده روسيا بتلغيم صديقه خوفك
مؤكدا ان الامر تم التخطيط له مسبقا
تمت مناقشه الهجوم الارهابيه على السد في
وقت سابق على التلفزيون الروسي وفي وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه ما يؤكد ان الامر تم
التخطيط له مسبقا روسيا سيطرت على السد
لاكثر من عام لا يمكن تفجيره من الخارج عن
طريق القصف القوات الروسيه قامت بتلغيمه
ثم تفجيره
قالت الولايات المتحده انها ليست متاكده
من هويه الطرف المسؤول عن تفجير السد في
اوكرانيا لكنها استبعدت ان تفعل اوكرانيا
ذلك بشعبها وارضها وذلك في الوقت الذي
تبادلت فيه
الاتهامات في الامم المتحده بشان
المسؤوليه عن الكارثه
[موسيقى]
سد النوفا كخوفكا يقع على نهر دنيترو على
مسافه 30 كيلومترا من مدينه خرسون بني في
عام
يعد جزءا من محطه كخوفكال هيدروكهربائيه
ارتفاعه يبلغ 30 مترا يحتوي خزانه على 18
كيلو مترا مكعبا من المياه سيطر عليه
الروس مع بدايه الحرب في فبراير 2022
اهميته تكمن في انه يمد شبه جزيره القرم
وجنوبي اوكرانيا بالمياه
ومياهه ضروريه لتبريد محطه النوويه
حدث وضرب سد نوفاكخوفكا في منطقه خيرسون
جنوبيه اوكرانيا ويحدث ايضا ان المياه
تغمر ما في طريقها وفي طريقها تتبادل
موسكو الاتهامات
الرئيس الاوكراني سارع الى القاء اللوم في
الهجوم على من وصفهم بالارهابيين الروس
ودعا الى طرد روسيا من اوكرانيا
واتهمت القياده الجنوبيه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه بتفجير السد
مدير مكتب الرئاسه الاوكراني اعتبر تدمير
السد جريمه حرب جديده وتشكل تهديدا لمحطه
زبروجيا النوويه وتهديد الاف السكان جنوبي
خرسون اما عمده مدينه نوفاكا خوفكا
الموالي لروسيا اتهم القوات الاوكرانيه
بقصف السد في المدينه فيما رجحت السلطات
المحليه المواليه لروسيا ان القصف تم
براجمات صواريخ لكن من المستفيد يقول
الجيش الاوكراني ان هدف روسيا من استهداف
السد هو تعطيل العمليات الهجوميه بزياده
منسوب نهر دنيبرو ما يصعب العبور للضفه
التي تسيطر عليها روسيا في حين يقول
الكرملين ان اوكرانيا تعمدت استهداف السد
لقطع امدادات المياه عن شبه جزيره القرم
والتغطيه على فشل هجماتها المضاده الاخيره
وفيما فتحت روسيا تحقيقا جنائيا بعد
انفجار سد نوفا كخوفكا دعت اوكرانيا مجلس
الامن الدولي الى اجتماع طارئ بشان ذلك
ايضا
[موسيقى]
دعا امين عام الوكاله الدوليه لتلقى
الذريه رفع الجروسي اطراف الصناعي في
اوكرانيا الى الضمان امني برك مياه
التبريد في محيط المنشاه زبولوجيا النوويه
بعد تفجير سد نوفاكا الذي يؤمن المياه
للمشاه النوويه ورد سفير لوس عبر العربيه
وقال ان الطلبه من روسيا بان لا تعرض امن
البرك للخطر سخيف وروسيا لا يمكنها تعريض
المنشاه خاضعه لسطرتها للخطر لم يمضي
يومنا على تحذير يامن عام الوكاله الدوريه
للطاقه الذريه رفيع الجروسسي من ان القتال
المتزايد في محيطي منشاه زابوريجيا يجعل
تامينها مهمه صعبه حتى استفاقت جروستي على
خبر تفجير سد نوفا كخوفكا الذي يؤمن مياه
التبريد للمنشاه جروس الذي سارع لاحاطه
مجلس المحافظين بطبيعات ذلك على المنشاه
النوويه قال ان مياه التبريد من خزان
تتوقف بعد ايام ولكنه تحدث عن بدائل
تؤمنها بوركو تبريدا ومجاوره للمنشاه
النوويه تكفي لبضعه اشهر
من الضروري ان تظل بروكو التبريد سليمه
يجب ان لا يحصل اي شيء يعرض سلامتها للخطر
لذا ادعو جميع الاطراف الى ضمان عدم
القيام بشيء لتقويض سلامتها العواقب يمكن
ان تكون خطيره
السفير الروسي من حق العليانوب الذي اراد
الاحتفال بيوم اللغه الروسيه في مقر الامم
المتحده في فيينا وجد نفسه مضطرا للتحدث
بالانجليزيه وليس بالروسيه كما اراد للرد
على دعوه جروستي جميع الاطراف تامين برك
التبريد
لا يحتاج الامر قول ان كل الجهود ستبذل
لتامين الامن النووي والقول ان روسيا تعرض
منشاتها النوويه للخطر هو امر سخيف نحن
اسسنا الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه كنا
من الدول المؤسسه وبالطبع دائما نتعاون مع
الوكاله ونتوقع ان تتعاون الوكاله معنا
وفيما تراقب الوكاله تاثير تفجير السد على
محطه زابوريا دقيقه بدقيقه كما قال جروستي
تحشد اوكرانيا هنا ايضا داخل مجلس
المحافظين لردود دوليه تدين روسيا التي
تتهمها بتدمير السد فور انتهاء اعمال مجلس
المحافظين هنا نهايه هذا الاسبوع سيتوجه
جراسي فورا الى منشاه زابوريجيا في زياره
كان مخططا لها مسبقا ولكنها الان باتت
اساسيه كما قال في محاوله لاحتوائ اي
تصعيدا محتمل يخشى ان يتسبب بكارثه
النوويه را غده بهنام العربيه
[موسيقى]
مجتمع ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان بن عبد العزيز مع وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتون بلينكن في جده واستعرض
الجانبان العلاقات الثنائيه بين البلدين
الصديقين كما استعرض اوجه التعاون في
مختلف المجالات وسبل تعزيزها الى جانب
تطورات الاوضاع الاقليميه والدوليه
والجهود المبذوله بشانها
صدر بيان من الخارجيه الامريكيه يؤكد قوه
العلاقه بين الرياض وواشنطن الممتده لاكثر
من 80 عاما واشارت الخارجيه في بيانها بان
العمل على الضمان الامن الاقليمي يعد احد
اسس العلاقه مع السعوديه
ركت الاستراتيجيه بين السعوديه وامريكا
بحسب بيان الخارجيه الامريكيه فان
السعوديه والولايات المتحده تجمعهما علاقه
استراتيجيه ممتده لاكثر من ثمانين عاما
حيث يعد العمل على ضمان الامن الاقليمي
احد اسس العلاقه مع الرياض وتعزز العلاقه
مع الرياض امن الخليج والقدره على ردع اي
تهديد لامن المنطقه
وقالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان هناك التزاما
بتعزيز الشراكه الامنيه مع الرياض عبر دعم
البنيه الدفاعيه الجويه والتدريبات
المشتركه وتعمل السعوديه والولايات
المتحده على حل ازمه السودان وحمايه
المدنيين وتمكين وصول المساعدات كما دعمت
السعوديه الجهود التي قامت بها الامم
المتحده في خفض التصعيد واحلال السلام في
اليمن
ورحبت الولايات المتحده بالخطوات التي
اتخذتها السعوديه لدعم اوكرانيا بما في
ذلك التعهد بتقديم مساعدات بقيمه 400
مليون دولار
دعا كبير الجمهوريين في لجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ الامريكي جيم ريش
دعا اداره الرئيس جوبادن الى تعزيز
العلاقات مع السعوديه باعتبارها شريكا
اقتصاديا مهما وامنيا ايضا لواشنطن اقل
ريش على تويتر انه على مدى 80 عاما كانت
السعوديه شريكا مهما في دعم المصالح
الامنيه والاقتصاديه المشتركه مشيرا الى
ان اداره بايدن تاخرت في تعزيز التعاون مع
المملكه
كشفت مصادر العربيه عن عوده المحادثات غير
المباشره بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع بتسهيل من السعوديه وامريكا في جده
وتركز اجنده المفاوضات على الترتيبات
الانسانيه ووقف اطلاق النار كما انخرط كل
وفد في اجتماعات منفصله مع مسهلي عمليه
الحوار واوضحت مصادر العربيه انه لم يتم
طرح اجنده جديده في هذه الجوله
في الاثناء افاد مراسل العربيه باندلاع
اشتباكات عنيفه بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع في الكلاكله بالخرطوم كانت الليله
الماضيه شهدت قصفا بالمدفعيه الثقيله
والطيران الحربي واطلاق نار متقطع جنوبا
مع تحليق المقاتلات وتعرضت احياء شرق
الخرطوم امس لقصف عنيف بالدفاعيه والطيران
بحسب شهود ايام في حين ابلغ سكان في محيط
مقر قياده الجيش بتعرض عدد من المنازل
لقصف عشوائي استمر حتى فجر اليوم
يعيش اقليم دارفور اوضاعا ماساويه بسبب
القتال الدائري في السودان الامر الذي دفع
حاكم الاقليم مني اركوم ناوي الى اعلان
دارفور منطقه منكوبه تحتاج للمساعده
بعد اكثر من خمسين يوما من القتال في
السودان لحقت باقليم دارفور اضرار عديده
تمثلت في اللجوء والتشريد لعدد كبير من
المواطنين بهذا الغليم حاكم اقليم دارفور
مني اركض اعلن بان اقليم دارفور يحتاج
لمساعدات عاجله وبان هذه المنطقه من
السودان تعتبر منطقه منكوبه لذلك تحتاج
الى التدخلات العاجله في اقرب وقت
والله بنطالب والناشد المنظمات الانسانيه
والخيريه انها تجينا راجع زي ما قالوا
تقدم يد العون لانه في ناس عانت بجد
بالذات في موسم الخريف ده ونحن والوف
عندنا في شهر 9 وشهر خمسه واربعه والفصوله
الخريف دي يعني في بيكون ركود اقتصادي صعب
جدا يعني والمنظمات دي بتسهل مساهمه كبيره
لو جاءتوا بتساعد في هالمشاكل كثير من
البيوت
القتال هو الداير بين الجيش والدعم السريع
خلف نزوحا كبيرا
كارفور فقد تضررت مراكز ايواء خاصه
بالنازحين بغرب دارفور تضرر معسكر نيفاشا
وكساب بشمال دارفور كمناطق يصعب ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه اليها مع ما تشهده من
قتال يومي وانعدام في السلع الاساسيه
وتحول الصراع في بعض المناطق بهذا الاقليم
الى صراع الكل ضد الكل مما خلف جرائم
كثيره جدا وتعتبر كارثيه بالنسبه للانسان
الان المويه الواحد يمشي بيت في او يجيب
صف من الصباح لحد الازر عشان يجيب برميل
وينتهي اليوم الثاني يعني معاناه لدرجه
اكثر من كده وبعدين
الماكل والمشرب في ناس كثير هيكون شغال
رزق اليوم باليوم في سوق والاسواق شغاله
والله الاسعار دي مبالغه فيها يعني اسعار
يوميا يعني في اليوم ممكن يزيد حاجه
بمرتين عندك مساله جاز الجاز اول امس ب
350 البرميل
يعني فتره السبعه هي لما بقينا الفتره من
نسائيه بيجوا الصباح
بخمسة هسه بخمسة وخمسين يعني شوف اسعار
غيار كما امتدت رقعه الصراع لتشمل مناطق
من جنوب دارفور وايضا محليات تتبع لشمال
دارفور من ضمنها محليه كتم الصراع ايضا
اثر على حركه الطرق بين المدن المختلفه
هنا في اقليم دارفور كما انه ساهم مساهمه
كبيره في عدم ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
من بورسودان الى دارفور صالح ابو علامه في
قناتي العربيه والحدث اقليم دارفور غربيه
السودان
نشرتنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
رئيسه وزراء ايطاليا تقول ان بلادها ستضخ
700 مليون يورو في تونس لدعم القطاعات
الحياتيه
اهلا بكم من جديد فتحت السفاره الايرانيه
في الرياض ابوابها بحضور مساعده وزير
الخارجيه السعودي للشؤون القنصليه علي
اليوسف ونظيره الايراني اضافه الى القائمه
بالاعمال الايرانيه في السعوديه حسن
نزارنكار وشمل الاحتفال رفع العلم
الايراني في السفاره وعددا من الكلمات
للمسؤولين الايرانيين وحضر الاحتفال اعضاء
سلك الدبلوماسيه في السعوديه من دول
خليجيه وعربيه وغربيه اعاده افتتاح
السفاره تاتي بعد ثلاثه اشهر من توقيع
الاتفاق السعودي الايراني لاستئناف
العلاقات بينهما برعايه صينيه
[موسيقى]
قالت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه لنائب وزير
الخارجيه وليد الخريجي بحث مع نظيره
الايراني للشؤون القنصليه علي رضا
تكثيف اللقاءات التشاوريه وسبل التعاون
لتحقيق المزيد من الافاق الايجابيه
للعلاقات الثنائيه بما يخدم مصالح البلدين
والشعبين
في مقابله مع العربيه اكد حسن زار انكار
القائم باعمال السفاره الايرانيه في
الرياض ان اعاده افتتاح السفاره امر
ايجابي مؤكدا على ضروره عوده العلاقات لما
له من منفعه اقتصاديه وتجاريه للبلدين
والمنطقه
عوده العلاقات بين الدولتين السعوديه
وايران ضروريه للمنطقه نرى ان عوده
العلاقات الضروريه ومستقبل العلاقات
بينهما مشرق وسيتم توسيع العلاقات
التجاريه والاقتصاديه والسياحيه المتبادله
بين البلدين وبشكل عام عوده العلاقات امر
ايجابي ويعود بالنفع على المنطقه اجمعها
[موسيقى]
فشلت الاطراف الليبيه في التوقيع على
اعلان بوزنيقه بشان الانتخابات الليبيه
فيما توقع وزير الخارجيه المغربي ناصر
بريطانيا ان يتم التوقيع على الاعلان خلال
ايام مشددا على اهميه ان تواكب هذه
التفاهمات اراده سياسيه حقيقيه لتنظيم
الانتخابات واقامه مؤسسات الدوله
اليوم هو هذه محطه مهمه في مسار البحث عن
حل الازمه الليبيه
محطه مهمه لان هاد الحوار مكن من الوصول
الى توافقات مهمه
فيما يتعلق
بتنظيم الانتخابات
في شقها الرئاسي وفي شقها
التشريعي البرلماني
هي محطه مهمه ويمكن تكون محطه حاسمه اذا
تمت مواكبتها لتطبيق كل التوافقات
هذه القوانين التي صدرت
يعني تتسم بالنقاط الاتيه اولا هي قوانين
لا تمنع احدا من المشاركه في العمليه
الانتخابيه هي قوانين تتسع لتشمل كل شخص
والشروط التي وردت فيها
بالامكان ان يدخل في العمليه الانتخابيه
اي شخص لا تتسم بالتفرد والاقصاء الامر
الاخر انها اوسعت المجال للاحزاب السياسيه
واتاحت الفرصه لهم بعد ان كانوا بعيدين عن
هذه العمليه واصبحوا لهم دور اساسي في
المشاركه في العمليه الانتخابيه وهذا
انجاز يحسب لها ايضا
حافظت على مشاركه المراه بشكل فاعل سواء
في مجلسي النواب او في مجلس الشيوخ وفق ما
نص على ذلك الاعلان الدستوري في تعديله
الثالثه عشر
قالت رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا
ميلوني ان بلادها ستضخه 700 مليون يورو في
تونس لدعم القطاعات الحياتيه ذات الاولويه
اعاقب اجتماعها مع الرئيس قيس سعيد اكدت
ميلوني انه يجب انتاج مقاربه واقعيه تمكن
تونس من الحصول على فرص للتمويل الدولي
في اليوم الرابع عشر من الاضرابات العامه
في فرنسا ضد قانون التقاعد انطلقت المظاهر
الرئيسيه في باريس حيث بدات تجمعات في
ساحه قريبه من الجمعيه الوطنيه وقد اعلنت
السلطات الفرنسيه عن نشر ما لا يقل عن احد
عشر الف عنصر من قوات الشرطه والدرك
لتامين التظاهرات والاحتجاجات التي انطلقت
في جميع انحاء البلاد بدعوه من الاتحاد
النقابي ضد قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد الذي
اثار في الفتره الماضيه موجه غضب عارمه
نشر الاعلان البريطاني ان مجموعات
بريطانيه كبرى مثل بريتيش ارويز وبي بي بي
سي تعرضت لهجوم الالكترونيه واسعه تم
خلاله سرقه بيانات الاف المواطنين وكان
هذا الهجوم مرتبط بمجموعه روسيه تدعى كلوب
متخصصه في الجرائم المعلوماتيه بحسب صحيفه
ديلي تيليجراف من جهتها اعلنت بي بي سي ان
البيانات المسلوقه تضمنت ارقام تعريف
الموظفين وتواريخ الميلاد وعناوين المنازل
وارقام التامين الوطني
ادلى الامير هذه النجله الملك تشارلز
الثالث بشهادته في المحكمه حول اتهاماته
بشان خرق ناشره صحيفه ميرور لخصوصيته هذه
اول الافاده لاحد اعضاء العائله الملكه في
المحكمه ليس كشاهد فحسب ايضا كصاحب دعوه
لمقابله صحيفه
الميه كبيره لمعركه الامير هاني القضائيه
ضد الناشري صحيفه
خصوصيته في حمله لفضح مخالفات الصحافه
الشعبيه البريطانيه من اجل انقاذها كمهنه
وفق زعمه
الامير هاري هو اول افراد العائله الملكه
يدلي بشهادته في المحكمه منذ 130 عاما
وبعد اداء القسم استهل محامي دفاعي مجموعه
الصحف ميرور اندروغرين بسؤال الامير هاري
فيما يتعلق مقالات قال انها تستند الى
موده تم الحصول عليها بشكل غير قانوني
اعدائه للصحافه كان واضحا في الرد على
اسئله هيئه الدفاع الصحيفه من رمي اللوم
عليها في الحاجه التي اودت بحياه والدته
ديانا الىما من اضطراب مع عائلته واصدقائه
من خلال جمع معلومات لمقالتها عن طريق
الخداع وانشطه غير مشروعه متسائلا عن
علاقه اموره الشخصيه بالمصلحه العامه التي
شكلت كيف ينظر اليه من قبل عامه الناس
شاهدا فحسب بل انه ايضا المدعي في هذه
القضيه وما يجعلها محاكمه ضخمه انه احد
افراد العائله الملكه وابن الملك تشارلز
يخوض معركه قضائيه ضد احد اكبر ناشر الصحف
بريطانيا
يوم ثاني من التدقيق في مضمون ادعاءات
مبرمجا في جلسه المحاكمه التاريخيه لكن
قرار الحكم النهائي في قضيته سيتطلب سنوات
لقناتي العربيه والحدث مصطفى زارو لندن
في نهايه شهاده التذكير بابرز عناوينها
اوكرانيا وروسيا تتبادلان الاتهامات بشان
السد امام مجلس الامن واشنطن تقول انها
ليست متاكده
ولي العهد السعودي يستعرضوا مع وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه العلاقات الثنائيه
والقضايا الاقليميه والدوليه
الاطراف الليبيه تفشل في التوقيع على
اعلان بوزنيقه رغم حديثا عن توافقات ليبيه
ليبيه مهمه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات